Brooklyn's truly like my best friend so
we've been together three years and I
feel like I'm living with my best friend
and also like the love of my life
he said I want to have 10 kids but it's
of course up to Nicola what do you make
of that number that is really sweet yeah
we we really do want a big family we
want to have some of our own kids and
then we really want to adopt kids too
but for now Nicholas focused on her new
true crime series welcome to
Chippendales streaming now on Hulu cuffs
and collars you are a genius she stars
as Playboy Playmate Dorothy Stratton who
was murdered by her estranged husband
the strip club's promoter
Eternal star camel nanjiani is
transformed into the ruthless
Chippendales founder Steve Banerjee who
stops at nothing to achieve the American
dream Juliette Lewis is a groupie White
Lotus Emmy winner Murray Bartlett is
Steve's business partner you and me
stick together or we go to war and
Steve's wife is played by Anna Lee
Ashford
I know you were so fiercely committed to
this role to the point where you gave
yourself back pain he's very tense this
is the FBI I started having this pain
underneath my shoulder blade that was
like going up to my ear in between takes
it would really hurt
You're a murderer okay so what's harder
the the Marvel training or actually
trying to nail this very emotional steam
it was certainly
more taxing and more exhausting you know
I'd rather like run around a forest than
like do these psychological drama yes
yes but it wasn't all serious are you
ready
[Applause]
yeah it's a really really fun show too
that's the thing because it's
make good men dancing
went on tour with the real Chippendales
25 years ago
it's like one big party on the road was
there any sort of a cast trip
check out a Chippendale show for
research purposes of course that cast
trip to a Chippendales Club I think is
in our future
[Music]